the second year of destiny - really was
a high point for the franchise Bungie
shifted its approach to adding on to the
game from a series of larger expansions
to more constant smaller content updates
while telling a larger story that
unfolded over the course of the whole
year
the forsaken expansion and the year that
followed it we're the best bungees live
shooter has ever been destiny - latest
expansion shadow keep continues to build
on that foundation in just about every
way while the new content hitting the
game is a lot of fun it's the smaller
improvements to the way destiny two
plays that have the greatest impact
shadow keep sends destiny - in a new
direction and it's clearly just the
first step in a much longer journey
bungees new approach to the game is to
create a year long story arc through
seasonal content and activities but as a
result parts of shadow keep can feel a
bit thin as we wait for things to
continue to unfold that's primarily true
of the story campaign which centers on
destiny one character Eris morn
and sees us returning to the moon for
the first time since before destiny -
launched Eris has learned that the hive
Destiny's semi magical death worshiping
alien faction has discovered something
sinister there and it's conjuring up
deadly phantasms of your previous foes
so in a way shadow keep is a big reunion
tour of old destiny content Eris is back
you return to the d1 location of the
Moon and you fight slightly watered-down
versions of big bad guys you've
previously defeated such as dark below
raid boss crota and destiny - vanilla
boss Gul since we haven't been back to
the moon for two whole years it's
something of an amped-up
nostalgia trip but we're still waiting
to reach the long-term end game content
that will wrap up some of these story
threads destiny - story campaigns are
often a bit quick and lackluster there
are some exciting missions particularly
as you band together with other
Guardians and tanks to raid the new
scarlet keep location but part of the
issue is that this is the prologue of a
larger story being told over the course
of the year and that can make it a bit
unsatisfying you'll probably be a bit
surprised when it's suddenly over after
4 or 5 hours of dedicated play but
revisiting the Moon is pretty cool
especially because Bungie has amped up
the location spookiness factor lunar
tunnels are filled with frightening
screams of hidden terrors there are
plenty of tough enemies to dispatch in
the
whole place carries an air of haunted
mystery it seemed so far we've only
scratched the surface of what's hidden
on the moon destiny is at its best when
it's full of secrets for the community
to discover and the game has already
provided a few big baffling mysteries
that have required everyone banding
together to work out the rest of the
expansion's new content is engaging as
well with shadow keep providing a
variety of experiences no matter what
kind of player you might be the new
nightmare hunts are pretty much mini
strikes making them quick palatable boss
fights that help you grab new gear a new
take on nightfall strikes the tougher
version of destiny 2's three players
strike activities are enticing thanks to
a ramping difficulty system that gives
you a challenge at a variety of power
levels exploring the moon has a lot to
offer as well though a lot of the
location is made up of old areas they're
deep and maze-like and every trip into
their depths feels dangerous
shadow keeps raid garden of salvation is
the most inventive of the expansions
content which is usually the case with
destiny's rates it represents pretty
much the toughest challenge in the game
and it's strange unique mechanics
require a great deal of coordination and
communication from your six player team
my team didn't finish it on the first
day but we had a blast working through
its various tough encounters as usual
destiny twos latest raid provides a
great incentive to keep pushing on the
gear grind bungees first bit of seasonal
content for shadow keep vex offensive
helps have more things to do for players
who burn through the expansion's base
content the six player activity has you
fighting off waves of enemies and it
takes after the menagerie activity from
last season it's a bit like a light
version of a raid activity requiring a
little more coordination than usual
without the punishing difficulty and
it's huge dump of rewards mean chasing
the best rolls for its many guns doesn't
feel like a chore next activity settling
down that ought to slow their progress
considerably great work
the content on offer and shadow keep is
fun to work through but the real
standout of the expansion is the way it
improves some of the underlying systems
of destiny 2's gameplay the big focus is
on pushing you to think about the way
you load out your character thanks to
the new armor 2.0 system previously in
destiny 2 armor had specific random
perks added to it which meant if you
wanted to focus on different kinds of
gameplay you had to switch to specific
gear but you spent so much time
switching between different pieces of
gear to push up your character's overall
power level that more nuanced stats like
how fast your grenades were charged or
how quickly you moved were easily
ignored shadow key changes that system
by making the perks movable between
pieces of gear with mods and unlike in
the past those mods are no longer
consumed on use that gives you more
chances to experiment with your loadout
to maximize the stats that give you the
kind of play style you're looking for or
help you excel in a specific role on a
team
it gives destiny to something of a more
RPG like focus and it encourages you to
spend more time thinking about how you
load out your character instead of just
equipping the items with the highest
numbers there are also big changes to
the leveling grind and shadow keep that
improve the game experience the early
climb up to the game's soft cap of 900
power is quick and relatively painless
with just about every piece of gear you
earn while playing improving on your
character once you hit the soft cap
things do slow down some as you have to
do tougher activities to get better gear
but shadow keep includes improvements to
keep you from getting bogged down the
new season past system and seasonal
artifact continue to give you rewards
based on experience you earn you get new
gear and cosmetic drops from the season
pass and additional power from the
seasonal artifact no matter what content
you're playing those two systems help
make the game feel more rewarding and
keep you from getting stalled as you try
to become powerful enough for garden of
salvation and other top-tier content it
also helps that between shadow keeps
activities on the moon the vex offensive
the raid and destiny choose usual
activities like strikes on the crucible
there's a variety of things to do to
keep progressing
shadow keep brings a big shift in the
fundamentals of destiny - and that has
only improved the game returning to the
moon is a spooky good time and while
shadow keep might not be as huge as
forsaken it still brings impressive
additions to the world that will take
time to fully explore but it's the
smaller more meaningful gameplay choices
that shadow ki provides that have me
wanting to jump back in and keep taking
on the vex and the hive
these are changes that destiny has
needed for a long time and they
represent a giant leap forward for
destiny -
[Music]